vice president kamala harris insulting
half of the country by claiming voter id
laws won't work in rural america
because apparently people who live there
aren't smart enough
i don't think that we should
underestimate what that could mean
because in some people's mind that means
well you're going to have to
um xerox or
photocopy your id to send it in to prove
you are who you are
well there are a whole lot of people
especially people who live in rural
communities who don't there's no
kinkos there's no officemax near them
just uh let her know there's no kinkos
in the rural areas
because there's no kinkos at all they
were bought out by federal express in
2000
something like that and then they had
their signs taken down in 2006.
score one for the gutfeld anyway
lawrence i look at this as progress uh
before
when they were making the voter id
arguments they were just insulting black
people
right it was just only black people no
it's white people we're
all stupid according to the democrats
that's progress
before before i address that point can
we just talk about kamala harris for a
second
she is not good off the cuff i love
it it is a why do i sit continue to send
her to do interviews i don't know
um it's a bad strategy for the white
house she's become a liability
for for the message because she's not
prepared ever even for the questions of
the border she's never prepared for the
but but it's i'm glad you point out the
point that she's now insulting all
people
yeah right i think they realized that
they lost especially with the black
businesses owners
they're pissed off right now that what
happened in atlanta the fact that their
businesses won't be
and the fact that they went to colorado
yeah
and their laws are worse i think it was
a slap in the face
and so just take her off just just take
her off
the trail no more interviews i don't
think she's prepared yeah you know what
i've said this before jessica in her
defense
she reminds me of me when i don't want
to do something
i just do the worst job possible on fox
and friends yes like
i always use the foster friends i was
terrible hosting fox and friends
they never asked me again it's a
strategy and i think she's doing a great
job
i find her arresting ironically
that's a tough backhanded one to go with
i i was just gonna lead with yeah i
wouldn't
obviously have not had a discussion
about voter id that revolved around
xerox machines and the proximity
together so you agree it was bad
i have not encountered a single person
of any political denomination
who defended it now the larger
discussion about voter id
that i think we're all excited to have
as adults at the table because i know
that you love it when i say here we go
from your ivory tower you know i live in
a rural community
[Laughter]
so here's the problem so 11 of americans
don't have
valid government photo id jim clyburn is
now endorsing that
well take it up with the brennan center
that's fast i will take it up with the
president
qyburn who i think you know really has
his finger on the pulse of where we
should be going to win elections and
kind of
i he ordained joe biden the nominee in
south carolina and then everything was
kind of
gravy from there is backing mansion's
plan which requires photo id but it can
be something like a utility bill
and i think that if republicans are
desperate or a phone bill
anything that you get at your home
because there are issues with people
matching birth certificates
um to their social security cards etc
especially for elderly voters
and black and latino communities so
let's talk about
getting somewhere with that so we can
get the john lewis for the people out so
if it's free
ids for everyone does that remove the
issue about voter id if everyone gets
the id
i i think i don't know i don't want to
just let's do it
yeah i think the thing is i think the
challenge that the democrats have is
they can never
actually find somebody that they could
show as an example
here's tom stevens he doesn't have any
they always talk about this group
but it's not there and it's because
jesse they know that the
it doesn't ids don't make it hard to
vote it makes it hard to cheat
and they're trying to make it sound like
oh this is making heart about to go did
show me one person
just show me one according to the
brennan center there are 400
40 million americans that can't prove
who they are there's 40 million of you
guys out there
wow we're gonna have to really dig into
that one
[Laughter]
i don't know about that one also i love
what the texas governor said he goes
we want to make it easier to vote harder
to cheat
how could you disagree with that easier
to vote
harder to cheat did you say that two
seconds ago
because he said it on the weekend so all
you want to do to make it harder to
cheat is what signature requirements
deadlines understanding the chain of
custody transparency in the count rooms
all you want to know is what's going on
and who you are as you say you are
none of that conflicts with making it
harder to vote
none of that so when i see kamala harris
you know how she gets that little
shoulder thing going
she goes it's a democracy
like that's a point what is that what is
like the thing she does with her head
that's not a deep point kind of like
this right is that her signature
movement yes so
it's almost like if you're going to lie
to me make it convincing so here's the
lie
like she actually cares about obstacles
devoting in rural america
she doesn't care if someone in wyoming
has to drive 40 minutes to a kinkos
she cares if someone in atlanta or
philly or detroit
has to wait five more minutes i'd almost
appreciate it if she said
i want to make it easier to vote for
everybody i don't care if there's fraud
i don't care there's going to be fraud
that's fine i just want to make it
easier
all we want are guard rails and and why
is that so difficult
no one has been able to answer that
question yet dana
uh to jesse's point like the democrat
party is always about the party of big
government and solutions like
we can solve the pandemic we can go
door-to-door
we can deal with you know systematic
systemic
racism we have all these big solutions
but then voter id is like oh my god we
don't know what to do
why don't we just get them free why
can't you guys just send out ids
i feel like voter id is this huge hurdle
for democrats over and over again but
the polling
amongst black americans and low-income
communities is that they like voter id
yeah so i think that's one of the
reasons that congressman clyburn is like
i could be for that
because you know what everyone's going
to be for that so you got to do it
kamala harris's team has been back
channeling for a while that
they are frustrated with the assignments
she's been given because they're hard
but she asked for this assignment yeah
and you know
in georgia one of the things that they
did remember that law the terrible law
you don't have to have a copy of your id
you just have to you just have to write
the id number
right on the thing so that they can
match it that's the requirement that
doesn't seem like too hard to do and i
think
pretty much everyone can get a pen not
if there's no kink
in south carolina nikki haley was
governor they did voter id there was a
big uproar she said fine
we'll pay for anybody we will come and
pick you up we will take you to the
place and we will take you home
she had i think something like 30 people
yeah in the whole state and then
that issue went away so it can go away
the last thing i would say is texas
democrats today
have all left the state in a huff
because
they are protesting this voter bill that
the texas legislature is putting through
the huffington post
what they're coming to dc why because dc
has the solutions
rather than staying in their state and
trying to work it out they're coming to
washington and please kamala harris fix
it for us
wait you mean you can leave work if
you're losing
you can just leave you can never leave
you're winning
never thought of that one before yes hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else